Bob hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to factorial
with Bob hi Bob and oil and oil oil so
long if you were right
oh yeah oh you explain this explain this
thing is a jerk alright so the way this
works yeah this was actually my idea I
don't know how it works though so this
is not so these little puddles of crude
oil on the ground you stick one of these
green pump jacks on there and it sucks
it up out of there
uh-huh shuts in this pipe here and it
puts it into this big thing that marks
and it next to yes it's called oil
refinery rizz Nielsen risen reals
Nielsen okay so when we when you click
on it ya know you click on it and it's
got assembly its basic oil processing
and now it's going oh nice so it's gonna
make all the other storage tanks are for
different types of oils oh absolutely
unnecessary no no they're perfect
it's no it's gonna make all of them it
made all of them oh wait you're you're
one only no no we make the one no you're
one down here is connected to the other
so you need to move it over just a
little bit just needs to move I got you
almost had it perfect but this is good
and good enough so that that's there and
then this goes like such as that see and
now we got three different products such
as look at that [ __ ] yeah I don't know
what to do with them but yeah yeah I
don't even honestly no a toy elizabeth's
oil yeah so this one has petroleum gas
this one has light oil and this one has
heavy oil which is good don't don't be
mad what why would I be mad
everything I would have when you say
don't be mad that just leave me the bag
don't be mad it's okay don't be mad I'm
not mad if you just talk to me like
converse emotionally like we need to
mark just don't be mad I'm dumb I'm not
mad I'm not getting mad I'm you're just
disappointed I'm supported okay there's
another thing called a chemical plant
which I'm going to put
down little below it right here so let
me rotate that actually I'm gonna I'm
gonna get a third pump track going cuz
why not okay cool
okay cool yeah okay so the chemical
plant can turn these things into other
things so if we pomp let's say I'm going
to pump the crude oil into oh my gosh I
think this is accelerated our pollution
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] as also if you if
you hit map and scroll all the way out
yeah does the dark does the black edges
is that the entire world
dude the world is infinite there is no
limit oh my god oh my god okay so we
need more storage tanks on the other
side because this is going to make more
storage tanks yeah so right now I'm
gonna have it make solid fuel oh you can
have its make solid fuel out of anything
huh yeah so right now it's making solid
fuel out of petroleum gas and you can
have a different chemical plant wait let
me see if it can do two different ones
it might be able to double storage
double storage on there we probably need
to do ground pipes because it's gonna be
hard to walk around if it's all just
gobbed up oh yeah that's probably a good
oh you're gonna kick okay some ground
pipes I'll start I'll start replacing
well sorry please okay good yeah but
this is cool because now we have a solid
fuel as being made out of it oh okay so
the output of this is solid fuel so
these storage tanks at the bottom aren't
necessary just yet umm that's for
advanced refinery when we have more
stuff to refine from it but this is good
what doing say yeah I didn't know what
we're finding was so easy if I don't
know anything could be possible ooh
but we can make plastic in this thing
yeah we can make plastic we have just
needs coal and uh this stuff and we're
at take a breath
we got cold right here
we have coal right here we can get coal
in there this cool right here right here
there's coal and I just blew up
everything
Oh ash Han well I just I destroyed
everything wow you really did just ruin
these soon every job I did it and there
and look at that look at all that
underground pipe work I just did why I
should go look at it
Wow Bob hang on I stopped I'm doctor I
figure I figured out some more stuff
watch this all right yeah ah look at
that like I open that it oh yeah
that's really nice Bob that is really
nice
thanks dad that's good job Bob I'm real
proud of your son
it is a great work you know what I am
proud of this I I I'm lagging so bad I'm
not even moving I got there I go one of
these days we're gonna fix this lag but
right now I'm just gonna live with it
apparently I got no other choice there's
no fixing that [ __ ] that's just how it
is okay so these storage tanks are
stupid and they don't work and you
should feel bad for making them but we
have inserters you [ __ ] then just okay
yeah just give up on your dreams of
whatever the hell happened here
and so we're how do we get this stuff
out of there like that out of there
like that it's going so slow we're out
of power where everything's out of power
I'll go fill you know I do I just need
to fire him I think that's the solution
oh come on
Reggie's doing okay he's not doing his
weird dance he's just moving feebly and
slow it's okay I need to worry about it
okay so now though we had everything was
completely out of [ __ ] coal yeah whoa
okay so coal has a value of eight mega
joules this solid fuel has a value of 25
mega joules so it's about oh my god need
to get that sell and fuel into
it yeah like the steam engine so I guess
the oil the oil refineries are only for
fueling steam engines but I guess we
don't need water anymore
no we need water to pump that's right we
started to steam yeah yeah we are always
gonna need water but yeah very crucial a
little bit not quite on water shal yeah
I got you yeah I understand okay plastic
bar that yeah not bad just slowly so I
thought I thought you said we were
making solid fuel um we were we can make
solid fuel out of any of these other
ones both the light and the heavy oil
can be made into solid fuel so we just
no can't those out to their separate
chemical plants and then they're good
understood nice this is nice this is
real nice work everybody
oh wow I can't believe we're doing it
like this is real stuff this is like
this is a big man yeah okay we're we're
really gonna be under attack well it's
not spreading the Cessna thought it
would by the time I got it there they're
gonna be mad at us
it's probably like what's giving us in
our favor is that every once in a while
our steam engines just shut off yeah
that's so we don't have to worry about
it it's totally fine yes it totally
those pigeons are supposed to shut off
because then we don't pollute so yeah
we're like conserving the environment
that's how you say that word we're
conserv environment Oh what's uh where's
the pipe only go straight that's stupid
is stupid it doesn't oh the underground
yeah that's why it's like that I'm not
just an idiot I understand the idea that
it would be really convenient to been
earlier with the concept and I
understand the desire to call me an
idiot but just like I'm not just want to
reiterate that all right so now you're
making solid fuel yeah so now I'm making
solid fuel I'm gonna put it in another
steel chest over here I don't think that
okay okay fine you do it or you can make
the other chemical preneur
that too fine whatever look I made I
made it in a steel chest Oh actually
it's an iron chest but whatever okay
whatever
now this one's producing from the light
man
oil is really useful holy crap yes
what's just awesome oh yeah well I got a
steel chest and I got a fast do daddy
sir
lay your pathetic little thing it
doesn't need to be this fast yeah yours
is just like whoa it's just really
excited about doing oil processing but
now this is cool this is awesome now we
just need the research to finish so we
can get logistics robots to take all of
the the solid fuel into the boilers yeah
I have to do that [ __ ] I wonder if it
can fly that far that's the big question
I [ __ ] hope so I mean we can create
like relay points yeah I mean we could
just belt this instead of having it be
in a box we could just belt it all the
way down but that would take forever
I'll be done take a lot of belt that's
uh that's a lot of belt are we producing
science now we were just not producing
copper for I don't know how long oh yeah
oh yeah cuz those silver knots were at
hole that's right yeah because you don't
have a coal supply over there yet dingus
and you got these two hole nearby and
you also have like these two electric
mining drills that just aren't doing
anything because they're out of mine but
whatever it's fun oh I'm gonna run a
coal supply over here since you've been
oh oh now we start fighting since you
bid yeah yeah yeah
Oh Bob I didn't hear what you said but I
feel really insulted I feel about you Oh
about you right now
oh I feel so bad hey actually gonna do a
fast conveyor belt cuz nice you nice
well me I'm on board with that I'm a
hundred percent okay with fast fast is
good doing it just to spite you okay I
guess I'm okay with this fighting but
deal okay actually now it's really cool
because we have so much
is going on here I'm literally like
maxing out the capacity for these labs
to hold [ __ ] out of this we're yeah
icing the [ __ ] out of it we're sine
signal
yeah and that's actually really good
because that means that we left these
science makers alone and they still
produced a lot of science so if you do
function
it's like didn't blow up it is like
magic man man
nice I'm actually do I'm really tickled
every time I look at this like I'm gonna
zoom out for everyone to enjoy like the
entirety of what we've made like from
the start of the point where we're
recording in this session and this might
be the last episode that we recording
this bunch but we've done a lot we've
done a whole lot like have we've
accomplished so many things like holy
[ __ ] look at all that we got oil
processing we got iron production out
the ass with so much iron production
we've got all this copper production
would get science we got science 1 & 2
we've got you know Bob's little piddly
pathetic signs hey welcome places tear
down from Akshay to see how much science
this is produced in that one cuz the
other in the none nothing the bench
would yeah actually the iron chest is
empty there's the sidewalk but you know
it's it's something even the even the
red one is kind of not doing anything
but you know it's cool the red one was
also pretty broken so that's not that
surprising okay alright then I didn't
want to burst your bubble too badly but
this oh the red one is also awful don't
worry we might have we actually have so
much science I'm gonna make more labs
I'm gonna make six more lips great
excellent I'm glad that your science is
working out so well thank you it's it's
going told them how to do that you
didn't you helped admittedly not respond
you you're away science you you helped I
will admit you helped you did help when
I got stumbled you did great wow that
fast build is moving quick yeah it's
fast a super smash like oh I see what
you're doing there I see oh yeah I'm
just gonna feed it into this [ __ ] and
then a nice hole nice nice
nice ah it might be more beneficial to
put it on the other side but whatever is
cool
it's whatever what what fine no you
don't have to redo everything no I'm I'm
gonna switch it around okay oh yes did
you do you got [ __ ] okay welcome trees
wasn't me it was trees oh yeah sure
whatever
okay so we are we are all out of time
for this UPS actually no I'm gonna put
the L no I'm not even close to done
making the lab suit yeah we're all the
time at the time
[ __ ] we're all done we're all add time
to this Epson work at all I'm an idiot
see told you this just leave me alone
no you're almost there you almost say
you just got to make one more back from
the yellow belt and then you got a then
you can put it on top of the thing and
it'll just dump on what you got move the
yellow belt one more back and then or
add one more right right where I'm
standing here and then you can curve the
red on to the top of the second one more
like no one more line down I don't
understand what you're saying can you
just do it I don't have any red and I'm
in the middle of making labs so you like
give this up over and then down on this
oh yeah there you go this yeah you get
you do it Bob
you helped it you're helping no no mark
one more over one more over you're
homeless you're sound yes I dare ya you
did it did it I'm so proud of you son
I'm so proud now that thing really books
it holy [ __ ] it does it's gonna be
[ __ ] backed up with coal charcoal over
here like five seconds okay so I'm going
to make a lab center lab boobs lab boobs
flat boobs
[ __ ] stupid laughs I could ride the
conveyor belt through the underground
conveyor belt without the ultimate theme
park ride have you tried it I judges
didn't work
[ __ ] I'm so sorry made me hold my wall I
didn't know I didn't oh yeah that's the
one I tore down with my bare hands after
I died I did you do all your way back I
remember it was a nightmare all right we
gotta like split up the split up the
science packs into these labs but I'm
lagging so badly that it's just not
working all right there we go
it's in there it's in there can you get
some red ones out of my red yes
you mean the functioning red one Oh
either what they both work great and
we're out of power again [ __ ] god damn
it so thank you everybody so much for
watching we're gonna progress on this in
another session probably down the road I
don't know Bob do you still have time
they're gonna woman okay we might do one
more so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we'll see you in
the next video I got